et on commence par du Taekwondo sea
sportif de l'école de taekwondo de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont participé
à l'US Open de Las Vegas le week-end
dernier ils sont trois à être présents
avec nous ce soir en plateau avec leur
coachs le président de l'école de
taekwondo il y a une Burel et on est
aussi du coup avec Oumaima alassac
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez eu la
médaille d'or dans la catégorie cadette
féminine moins 44 kg mais dit elle Azar
bonsoir alors vous vous avez eu la
médaille de bronze dans la catégorie
cadet masculin moins 53 kg et enfin
Khalida Haddad bonsoir vous avez
remporté la médaille de bronze dans la
catégorie senior féminine moins 67 kg
alors première question à tous les trois
ça s'est plutôt bien passé la
compétition sur place comment est-ce que
vous l'avez vécu franchement ouais c'est
bien passé on était très bien préparé
mais ça aurait pu se passer mieux mais
c'est très bien passé
c'était la première fois que vous alliez
aussi loin pour une compétition pour ma
part c'est la deuxième fois la première
elle avait eu à Miami après c'est
toujours c'est un peu un rêve de
combattre là-bas c'est Las Vegas c'est
ça fait rêver et puis ça c'est bien
passé au début le décalage avec avec des
caries c'était compliqué mais du coup on
s'est vite adapté et puis voilà et pour
vous deux c'était la première fois ça
fait la première fois les États-Unis
après ça fait plaisir première fois aux
États-Unis la médaille ça fait plaisir
moi aussi c'était la première fois
c'était c'est bien passé et donc c'est
un rêve pour vous en tant que jeune je
suppose de voyager et de et de faire son
sport avec passion le taekwondo
Yann Burel du coup je vous en parlait
aussi en début d'émission c'est une
fierté pour vous je suppose comment
est-ce que ça s'est passé concrètement
sur place c'est pas la première fois que
que vous avez des compétitions de ce
genre à l'international c'est c'est une
école qui devient de plus en plus connue
dans le secteur oui alors on a été
plusieurs fois meilleurs clubs de France
cadet junior chez les jeunes donc on a
déjà une reconnaissance nationale
importante les jeunes que vous avez ici
ont déjà fait des médailles nationales
sur la plus haute marche donc ce sont
pas des débutants on envoie vraiment
l'élite du club ils sont tous athlètes
de haut niveau ils ont fait une
acclimatation de quelques jours à Los
Angeles où on connaissait un coach
sportif qui les a accompagnés quelques
jours pour l'adaptation avant de se
diriger vers Las Vegas donc ils ont déjà
fait quelques compétitions
internationales que ça soit avec le club
ou en équipe nationale donc qui sont
déjà un peu habitués quand même aux
compétitions internationales ils seront
à nouveau en Belgique ce week-end pour
participer à un open puisque le but
c'est grappiller des points dans le dans
le classement mondial et éventuellement
ceux hisser
au niveau du classement olympique et
pouvoir participer aux Jeux Olympiques
il y a d'autres grandes échéances
échéances cette année pour eux
oui alors il y a encore des championnats
championnats du monde qui seront à venir
pour les pour les plus jeunes et après
il y a des Open internationaux auxquels
ils vont participer alors on va revenir
un petit peu sur vos trois parcours à
l'US Open à Las Vegas Oumaima à la SEC
vous avez enchaîné quatre tours en
gagnant vos quatre rounds et vous avez
aussi remporte vous l'avez aussi
remporté contre la numéro une américaine
à domicile aux États-Unis on peut dire
que vous avez survolé cette compétition
oui ça a été très dur sur les débuts de
compétition et après sur les suivants
combats c'était plus facile c'était plus
facile de A à Z vous avez trouvé ça
difficile où il y a quand même eu des
complications il y a eu beaucoup de
complications avec le stress et tout
mais après ça allait mieux mais comment
est-ce que vous vous préparez il y a une
préparation physique mais une
préparation aussi mentale je suppose oui
comment comment est-ce que ça se passe
c'est plus dans les entraînements et
tout genre par exemple sur la piste ou
concours et à l'entraînement
Mehdi de votre côté c'était un peu plus
compliqué j'ai cru comprendre vous avez
bataillé jusqu'au bout pour obtenir
cette médaille de bronze et vous l'avez
remporté vous l'avez bien mérité
qu'est-ce qui était compliqué pour vous
c'était des concurrents forts face à
vous c'est un adversaire très fort avec
la fatigue de la journée le combat il
s'est ça a été très tard dans le soir
donc avec la fatigue de la journée mes
deux tours juste avant c'était très dur
et c'est pas grave
vous avez quand même remporté
une belle médaille Yann Burel la
concurrence c'était était rude lors de
cette US Open concurrence très rude il y
avait des champions des numéros en
mondiaux
Oumaima elle a battu une fille qui était
troisième ou Championnat du Monde ou
même a aussi fini troisième au
championnat du monde mais elle a donc su
battre une adversaire qu'elle avait sur
le podium donc ils ont vraiment eu ils
ont su élever leur niveau de performance
Rida aussi enseign ant il y avait un
niveau très élevé avec des champions du
monde des coréennes donc c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment une
compétition très relevée justement
comment ça s'est passé pour vous
bien il y a une purée elle l'a dit les
adversaires étaient avaient un niveau
très élevé comment est-ce que ça s'est
passé pour vous la compétition c'est
vrai que la catégorie enfin ma catégorie
toi c'était enfin il y avait un niveau
très élevé il y avait des notamment la
meilleure à tête américaine et puis il
m'a les deux premiers combats ça a été
difficile parce que c'était des
combattants assez agressifs et elles
envoyaient mais ça c'est bien passé
après en finale j'avais j'ai rencontré
une une athlète coréenne que j'avais
déjà eu auparavant j'avais perdu contre
elle mais j'ai pas perdu de la même
façon c'était une défaite sur le fil
j'ai perdu au dernier round à égalité
mais c'est elle qui avait l'avantage
vous pensez aux Jeux Olympiques
peut-être pas à ceux de Paris mais
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs mais est-ce que
vous pensez à cette échéance les Jeux
Olympiques plus tard
c'est le projet
Mehdi Oumaima pareil franchement ce sera
un rêve de qu'on fait tout pour pour y
arriver un jour et vous Yann Burel c'est
aussi un rêve
c'est le rêve de tout coach et de devoir
ces jeunes parvenir à participer aux
rêves olympiques et pourquoi pas y
ramener une médaille donc pour pour
Paris ça va être un peu juste pour eux
ralidal est encore en course elle a une
adversaire très dure dans la catégorie
au niveau national mais voilà tout est
encore possible à un peu plus à 500
jours maintenant des Jeux Olympiques et
bien merci en tout cas à vous quatre
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
d'avoir partagé votre expérience en
plateau